so yesterday we talked about how Marvel
Studios seemingly is going a very comic
accurate route with the MCU and today we
have even more news to back this up it
seems like Avengers Secret Wars on the
MCU is going to be really really close
to the events that happened in secret
wars in the comics however it's not just
going to all happen in one movie this is
going to take place in the MCU
throughout multiple movies then it will
all ultimately lead up to the reset or
the reboot of the MCU an ending to one
chapter of the MCU and the beginning of
another chapter now something to keep in
mind is that Marvel studios's plans have
kind of changed partially at least not
fully but unfortunately they did have to
change some things because of Jonathan
major and if you haven't heard Jonathan
major who played King the Conqueror he
who remains and all the other variants
in the MCU was found guilty in court and
Marvel Studios has officially fired him
so naturally some of Marvel studios's
plans have changed however the new plans
are still pretty dang good and of course
they're all going to lead up to the huge
event that is Avengers Secret Wars which
could actually be three movies there is
still talks of Avengers Secret Wars the
actual movie the final Avengers film
being split into two different parts and
from what I've read online most fans
agree that if they are going to try to
tell this huge Amazing Story with all of
these different characters coming in
from a bunch of different universes they
would be okay with Secret Wars being a
part one and a part two if they needed
more time to tell a better and complete
story rather than rushing everything
into one movie but as it stands right
now we could be getting an Avengers 5 a
secret Wars part one and a secret Wars
part two with the part two or the final
Secret Wars movie being an actual battle
world movie so let's dive into these new
reports but if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
any of the latest Marvel and MCU news
also if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items only 4 days left to
enter the giveaway the winner picks one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month so yesterday we had this
report from credible Insider my time to
shine hello she stated on Twitter
beyonder is still the main villain for
Secret Wars that will be their excuse to
recast Kang now we covered this pretty
in depth yesterday so after this video
if you want to check that out you can
but after that The Insider cryptic HD
quality who as far as I know has a 100%
track record replied to this tweet
stating yes and what I heard is they
won't explicitly present him as beyonder
king until the aftermath of the 616
collapse when he will then go on to
establish battle world now this is
different than what we have heard in the
past but of course I think it all ties
together now what we heard in the past
was that that in Deadpool 3 we were
basically going to see the establishment
of battle World in Deadpool 3 the TVA
was going to go around to different
universes and start Gathering heroes
from these different universes and bring
them all into one specific Place
establishing that place as battle world
and that's when everybody started going
okay that's pretty close to what happens
in the comics however instead of the
beyonder it's the TVA but what if this
is the beyonders plan have the TVA start
to gather all of these Heroes and put
them into one place there is one major
difference between what the beyonder
does in the comics and what the TVA is
going to do in Deadpool 3 in Deadpool 3
they are gathering the heroes of the
Multiverse to come together and Fight
King the Conqueror in battle world the
beyonder collects the heroes and the
villains and has them fight each other
which I believe is going to happen and
that's what I believe cryptic HD quality
and my time to shine hello and the other
insiders are hinting at a true battle
World story where the beyonder come
comes in and says that he is behind
everything and it will essentially kind
of be like he who remains meeting Loki
and sylv and telling them I paav the
road for everything you did I led you
here because keep in mind although it's
still kind of vague at this point but it
does seem like the beyonder that we're
going to get will be some type of King
variant whether Marvel studi simply says
hey this is the beyonder and he is a
Kang variant or maybe Kang steals the
power of the beyonder either way
whatever this beyonder variant is going
to be he is going to have the power of
the beyonder so he definitely has the
power to manipulate everything going on
in not just one but multiple universes
so the TVA collecting all of the heroes
from a bunch of different universes that
could be all according to the Beyond's
plan and cryptic HD quality specifically
said that they will explicitly present
him as beyonder King in my time to shine
hello states that he is still the main
villain the beyonder that is for Secret
Wars and that's their excuse to recast
Kang implying that Kang is the beyonder
so what we believe is going to happen
according to previous reports now is
that throughout multiple movies Deadpool
3 Avengers 5 maybe Doctor Strange 3 the
Multiverse is going to essentially
collapse the Council of Kings the three
main Kings am mortis ramut and the
Scarlet Centurion are essentially going
to win and they are going to take over
the Multiverse and it seems like the
Avengers aren't really going to have a
way to defeat them that's when Alex
Perez over at the cosmic circus says
that they are going to bring in another
king that is much stronger than the
others and that is the beyonder king and
he basically said that the Avengers
aren't going to be able to defeat the
Council of Kings but the beyonder king
comes in and defeats them but the
beyonder king even though he is stronger
than the Council of Kings has a greater
weakness and we believe we know what
that weakness is because in the comics
Dr Doom comes along and takes the powers
of the beyonder so we believe that
somebody could come along and take the
powers of this King beyonder ver that is
if they are trying to go really really
comic accurate which I believe they're
going to do because if you truly give
this Kang beyonder variant the powers of
the beyonder he really can't be stopped
unless you take his powers and that's
probably where people like Reed Richards
of the Fantastic 4 are going to come
into play in Avengers Secret Wars and
then keep in mind after this movie the
MCU is going to reset in the new report
cryptic HD quality specifically said
they are going to present beyonder king
after 616 collapses so our main universe
that we have known and love since the
very first Iron Man film is going to be
gone essentially and after Secret Wars
when we start the next chapter of the
MCU it might exist in another universe
that will have some remains of our
universe in it that way it's not a hard
reboot but it most likely won't be the
616 Universe anymore so here is
essentially what we are looking at to
possibly happen in the MCU moving
forward everything's going going to
essentially hit the fan in Deadpool 3
this is where we will truly start to see
universes get destroyed incursions will
start to happen throughout the
Multiverse and this is where the TVA
will start to gather heroes from a bunch
of different universes and bring them
into one place with the purpose and the
hope of bringing them together to go up
against the Council of KS Doctor Strange
3 will most likely go further into this
looking into the incursion since Doctor
Strange has caused some incursions
himself Doctor Strange 3 will most
likely explore how to fix Inc inions
however I don't think they're going to
really come up with a solution since the
entire Multiverse is going to start to
fall apart there's just going to be too
many incursions to fix then we go into
Avengers 5 which was supposed to be king
Dynasty but reportedly is just Avengers
5 at this point regardless I still think
that the Avengers are going to lose in
this film and that will build right into
Secret Wars either a secret Wars part
one or just a secret Wars film that is
one movie now what could happen here if
they're going to do a three-part movie
Avengers 5 and then Avengers Secret Wars
part one and then part two is that in
Avengers 5 The Avengers that we know
right now the new Avengers team with
Captain America Spider-Man shehulk
regular Hulk Wong Doctor Strange whoever
they decide to be a part of the new
Avengers will fight and lose to one
variant of Kang just one they are then
going to realize that there are infinite
amounts of Kang variants out there and
that's when they really start to come
together and talk about the Multiverse
and this is where they could start to
bring together heroes from a few
different univers together that could
lead us into Avengers Secret Wars part
one where based off of the reports that
we've heard I believe they will lose
again in this movie they might not have
a lot of multiversal Heroes maybe only a
few of them used because it's said that
the TVA is going to gather a multiversal
team but we know that they're going to
collect heroes from many different
universes so maybe at first they decide
to use a specific group of Heroes we're
talking Wolverine Deadpool Toby Maguire
Spider-Man if the new Fantastic for
movie takes place in Another Universe
they're going to use some of the members
of the Fantastic 4 on this team as well
and then of course Tom Holland
Spider-Man probably Doctor Strange maybe
a few others they'll go up against the
Council of kings and then they'll lose
but then the beyonder will come in he'll
defeat the council but then he'll
announce that he is going to have his
battle world and that's when the next
movie comes in Avengers Secret Wars part
two battle world that'll be one heck of
a cliffhanger but based off of the
reports that we've been hearing it seems
like this is kind of the trajectory that
the Avengers films and the other
multiversal films in the MCU are going
to follow now of course if Avengers
Secret Wars remains one movie then in
that one movie they will fight the
Council of Kings lose but then the
beyonder king comes in defeats them and
then they have to fight beyonder King
and maybe even fight each other if the
beyonder really does establish a true
battle world like he does in the comics
but let me know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below would
you like this would you not like this
and would you like Avengers Secret Wars
to be a two-part movie or just one movie
let us know your thoughts don't forget
to like this video And subscribe you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof